hey everybody it is another episode of
overrated underrated with me your host
garyvee drock is in the building i'm in
a solid mood
let's get into the show
did you work out no okay then you're
just doing this so
you mean yesterday my chest still
yesterday but not yet after this
doing it after fortnite fortnite
underrated i'll tell you why wherever it
is right now in the heat of its moment
for me it feels on a decline from its
apex i will go to the grave with
fortnite probably having two more spike
moments in its culture like 12 years
from now just predicting right now the
reboot of fortnite in 21 years nvr smash
hit anything white heat for over 18
months can always be recalled nostalgia
fortnite underrated right now because i
feel like it's declining people think
it's declining i see the longer tail
knight
wildly underrated incredible artist
devastating loss to
the culture and uh i am a fan coding and
programming coding and programming is
properly rated i'll tell you why 10
years ago wildly underrated now i feel
like a lot of parents are pushing their
kids to coding but there's more and more
people doing that i think it's properly
rated because it's respected properly
people are comped properly it's it's
foundational to society properly rated
fashion inferior fast and furious
overrated
people are emotional about this it has
to be overrated for me listen i know
it's epic i know the rock's in and i
think right vin diesel is rocking it
yeah he is i read all the comments for
overrated underrated so i'm ready for it
overrated smt 500. you know i don't do a
lot of wall street stuff but i will say
that it is overrated i think that um
there's a lot of ways i believe because
of what's going on with technology over
the next decade
to do more interesting even safer
betting than the historic nature of the
s p 500 as we see crypto as we see
alternative investing as we see people
building their own businesses just think
there's some other behaviors that yeah
i'm just i'm gonna go with overrated the
rock dwayne johnson
massively underrated and i'm about to
love him even more because he's putting
out a sitcom based on wrestling that has
the macho man in it and junkyard dog and
the iron chic baby and andre the giant
and um
so fired up him and ryan reynolds are
like the two individuals on earth who i
understand very well they are incredibly
talented in their ability to do film and
television the attention they're very
thoughtful they're nice and they're
[ __ ] entrepreneurs for real building
real businesses those guys are going to
the [ __ ] moon and i admire both of
them a lot i think the rock and i'm just
going to throw ryan reynolds but both
are beautiful [ __ ] faces in my hands
right now post-production two incredibly
underrated men millennials millennials
are
you know
millennials are underrated first of all
to all the you know greatest generations
the boomers who [ __ ] on millennials all
day long you [ __ ] raised them you
created the entitlement ecosystem it may
be millennials would be better in your
mind boomers if you didn't give them
fifth place trophies because you didn't
want to deal with them being sad there
are boomer parents that complain to me
about kids all the time because of my
content i literally opening question do
you give your kid money yes how old are
they 24 i'm like you're the problem ikea
ikea is underrated just incredible
execution plenty of serviceable stuff
people love to go there just to even
[ __ ] experience it i think it's
underrated nothing napping is overrated
what the [ __ ] are you doing napping at 4
p.m
i don't like it by the way the comments
just lit up people [ __ ] love a good
nap drock you like a nap i love a good
night
i rate it 1999 pokemon charizard hollow
first edition cfa10 million dollar card
that's my answer which means it's
underrated because i think it's a 300
000 plus card right now pokemon is an ip
that sits at the highest level there's
like brouhahas and like riots at
mcdonald's actively right now as we film
this because of pokemon cards so the
greatest pokemon card in the world in a
perfect condition
yes i would say that is underrated
mcdonald's that was a funny segue
mcdonald's i'm gonna go with properly
rated i sit on the board of bojangles i
think it would be too much of a conflict
for me to
subjectively make a decision on qsr's
here's what i would say i loved 20 years
ago chicken nuggets from mcdonald's so
much that i can't breathe they've made
them healthier
i liked the bad stuff it was delicious
ceviche is wildly underrated i could
live on ceviche you could see my energy
up seafood ceviche all kinds of ceviche
give me a little jalapeno with my
ceviche i'm about ceviche
underrated
wildly underrated anybody who doesn't
understand the power of that platform
its impact
i don't talk about it enough um
underrated robin i don't use it
obviously it was incredibly underrated
for everybody then everybody got mad at
it but i think all the brokerages had to
do it it just had the heat i think it's
properly rated i just don't have a good
enough read on it birthday wine rose
wine is overrated now empathy rose is
the [ __ ] but as a whole it's too hyped
right now
rose wine
slightly overrated there's a lot of epic
white wines like a suave like a pinot
gris like a grooner from austria there's
these epic 20 dollar white wines that
people are not discovering and i think
they should rose overrated slightly
alternative whites not named chardonnay
sauvignon blanc and pinot grigio
underrated new balance i like new
balances i think they're underrated taco
tuesday taco tuesday is properly rated i
don't even think about it fiverr fiverr
underrated very good platform especially
for a ton of entrepreneurs record labels
overrated duolifa a properly rated
intake
aj's underrated because something i'm
working on quite a bit in my career in
life is candor what drives me crazy is
that i think competitiveness is like the
secret right drock
and like i know with that tom brady and
michael jordan literally exist because
of competitiveness i have it and it's
obvious aj has it equally and it's not
obvious so i think he's underrated for
his competitiveness which i know is the
secret ingredient to the whole [ __ ]
game he's a good man underrated
cube i'm gonna go with
underrated for one reason because i want
you to show this clip
you love rubik's cube yeah rubik's
cube's dope you were super hardcore on
it
yeah like as a kid you got real good at
it no i only learned this like a year
and a half ago and what you're good now
i'm okay yeah i like it it's fun
that was logic on the askgaryvee show
doing a rubik's cube in like three
seconds and to this day i still love it
but there's a different reason that
rubik's cubes are underrated it's
because of my cousin bobby who i love
very much big shout out to bobby
schifrin who i worked with every day in
my wine library career we were extremely
close i actually miss him a lot and have
to do a better job of trying to have
more time with him he was the first
person i ever saw do a rubik's cube we
were super poor growing up in that
immigrant life and i thought he was the
coolest leather jacket bicycle rubik's
cube i was like that's the fonz that's
how i thought about bobby valentine's
day valentine's day is underrated that
is the most capitalistic manufactured
holiday out of thin [ __ ] air
brilliance which by the way i'm gonna
use this platform to sing a huge
grievance why in a world of mother's day
father's day valentine's day do we not
have kids day in america i think we have
a major issue there should absolutely be
on a random and it should be a day off
may 7th should be kids day and we should
have it off and you should buy kids
gifts and everyone's like what about
birthdays and christmas i'm like but
everybody gets that i never understood
why kids they didn't exist
jay-z underrated hip-hop
is as important to society as it gets
which means forever it will always be
and jay-z is one of the five to 10 to 15
most important humans to ever be
involved in it he's an entrepreneurial
business icon he's somebody who's in his
50s right now that is as cool as anybody
in society if he walks in a room in his
50s i think that's cool i think that's
underrated jc is underrated youtube i
hope you enjoyed that please leave a
comment please subscribe please hit the
share and send it on the socials
[Music]